from history to the delicious foods
hispanic heritage month wouldn't be the
same without the beautiful sounds of
music that's right one mariachi ensemble
is making quite an impact adam cardona
brings us the
the vegan story because brian likes the
vegan stuff the meat cut with the bowls
is an all-female mariachi ensemble and
it all started with a group of friends
who were in college
director mariachi margaritas carina vela
says the all-female mariachi group
launched in 2009. most mariachis were
male dominant and we wanted to do
something different
vela says she is originally from mexico
but she says she didn't get inspired
until she came to the states that
culture that the music wearing the the
outfits or mariachi traje it's something
that i actually learned to love here in
the u.s because it made me close to my
roots from mexico and it actually
happened here in the us which is
something that is very special to me she
says over the years the ensemble has
performed at all kinds of events ranging
from celebrations to funerals but one
performance has been the most memorable
we were invited to accompany angela
aguilar leonardo hilar and pepe aguilar
on their opening show of for actually
canelo's
walking opening show for his previous
fight
that for us i would say it's the one i'm
gonna always remember the mariachi
margaritas ensemble practices weekly and
performs every weekend at events and
venues but it takes more than just
practice for their success it has to
start with respect it has to start with
friendship and respect and i think that
it has brought us this far because of
how we respect each other as musicians
assistant director abigail gonzalez has
been with the group for almost seven
years playing guitar and singing as an
all-female mariachi influencer i would
love that
to encourage young girls to to pursue
something like this the group is made up
of multiple female members and they say
they are one big family working together
to put on the best performance possible
[Laughter]
and we all put
the like whatever benefits the group
first like we put ourselves second
because the group comes first they all
agree that being part of the group is a
great experience and embracing culture
is important mariachi more than anything
represents our culture represents who we
are as people mariachi music brings joy
to anywhere we go reporting in
brownsville i'm adam cardona